who do you envision your audience's
being I know a lot of people in the
spiritual community will probably
definitely resonate with the film what
about people that might still be in that
intellectual you know maybe working that
corporate job how do you think you would
reach them with the film or maybe is it
when they're ready the teacher will
appear what's a little bit of both but
we very purposefully mainstreamed as
film as much as we could because I came
about it originally where i was going to
share a lot of things about energy and
the chakras and the subtle connection
between our physical body and the earth
i came to find out there really is a
scientific connection between the heart
and the resonant fields of earth that
are measurable but we wanted to go after
the audience of the people who don't
have the tools yet who might hear them
from other people oh there's something
in this film for me and that's why we
did it as a bit of a montage a number of
different stories instead of just one
story of them for example my recovery
from a childhood of abuse we have
someone who has had cancer some people
who experience job loss and loss of
loved ones and so we wanted to give a
touch a little bit of everything so that
anybody would resonate with the
mainstream message is you can heal your
heart by going into the feeling step by
step and that was our goal was to reach
not just the choir but to potentially
touch those who really are seeking and
our beginners in this process of how do
I make my life better and how do i
create a meaningful impact in the world
around me
you